hi so today I want to talk to you about
the concept of deep work so when we look
at artists presidents and also
scientists we really see that they craft
dedicated time to put in the hours for
Deep work and I find it personally a
really interesting concept and I've seen
in my own work when I really put
dedicated time towards deeply working
into my science and into my craft that I
get better a lot faster and then I get
results quite fast and today I want to
give you some tips tools and techniques
to really allow for this deep work to
happen so a deep work was kind of
introduced by Carl Newport under the
name deep work but I've known it for a
little bit longer under the name of flow
and I think that when we look at
different schedules of people that we
can really see that most artists and
most scientists usually have these
dedicated time looks for deep work so I
personally really like this book daily
rituals by Mason Curry and he really
Dives deep into these daily rituals of
famous people people so I want to show
you one that I really like and it's the
first one by Benjamin Franklin and he
demonstrated his schedule that was first
in the morning to wake up and do the
question what good shall I do today so
we've talked about doing one thing every
day and I think that kind of amplifies
this then there's a noon afternoon and
in the evening he has another question
which is what good have I done today and
I really like his schedule but today I
want to give you the tips and tricks to
kind of design your own schedule such
that you may optimize your workflow for
deep work so the first thing first is to
kind of know thyself and I think knowing
yourself and knowing your own optimal
working hours is really important
because when I read the book of Mason
Curry on daily virtuals I really saw
that different artists different
scientists have different Peak moments
so some of the artists he describes they
say that they work best at night so they
always craft in a few hours every night
that they work on writing their book for
example or painting whereas other people
in this book are really early morning
people and they dedicate the time in the
morning so every morning they have a
block of around three hours where they
work and I think in general it's not
really important when you work although
all the morning people on YouTube would
say differently but I think it's more
important to be consistent every day
that you have a couple of hours every
day where you are alone without friends
and distraction of your phone or
computer and when you really dedicate
your time towards that one project or
one goal that you want to go towards so
the second thing I find personally
really important is to optimize your
space for deep work so for example I
have my desk behind me and I usually
only do work at this desk so I don't
really do leisure time or I don't do
gaming I don't watch YouTube videos at
this desk I only do work and I
personally also like going for example
to different spaces like a library or
Cafe when I'm kind of stuck or when I
want to work on another dedicated
project so personally I really like
writing in cafes and I think it's kind
of your task to find a space in your
house that's dedicated to deep work and
maybe some of you will have only a one
space bedroom but even then I think you
can dedicate a tiny corner of your room
or even a space in your bed where when
you sit there you will only do deep work
and I think this slowly kind of rewires
the way we think about that space and
once we enter that space we will
automatically go into this flow of deep
working the third thing I find really
important is to have a clear goal so
every deep working session I would have
one goal or one thing I kind of want to
finish so for example it could be making
a YouTube video but it could also be a
dedicated programming practice that I
wanted to do that day or having
something finished for my science right
but every day could be different but I
think it's quite important to to have
this one goal quite clear for yourself
that you would work towards that during
your deep working hours because I think
if we go into deep work without any goal
or any direction we usually just end up
kind of twiddling our time away so it's
really nice if before each session you
set a clear goal and the fourth thing I
want to talk about is to be a little bit
flexible with your time so sometimes we
set in two hours and then immediately
after these two hours we plan in
something else but one thing I've
noticed a lot is that sometimes I just
have really good sessions and I kind of
want to keep on working all day or all
evening and then if I have something
immediately planned after that's just
kind of a sad thing right because you're
finally in this flow and this amazing
deep work mindset so what I would do is
to be a little bit flexible with your
schedule so I personally don't really
over plan things I usually set dedicated
time blocks for things I want to
accomplish that day but the rest of the
time is usually a little bit more free
such that if I want to continue my two
hours of deep work to the rest of the
day that this is possible and the fifth
thing is just something I personally
find really important and that's the
Mind Body Connection and I've talked
about this a lot but I want to keep
emphasizing this so I think personally
for myself I'm usually pretty jittery
and pretty high energy throughout the
day so if I don't move I get really
stuck in my thoughts sometimes so I
think it's really important to also when
you do deep work you can also move
around like some of us think when we do
deep work we have to be really focused
and really intensely scheduled in one
place but I think it's also okay to
bring in movement throughout these deep
working sessions because I think once
you are stuck in a little problem for
example to walk around or to go outside
or to take your work to another place is
kind of brings new energy to your
thought process and I think this kind of
movement of flexibility in your body
kinda allows your mind to sometimes
relax and really solve the solutions a
lot lot faster than if you just stay
dedicatedly at your spot for
six hours so yeah these were my tips on
deep work for now I would also highly
recommend to read the book he really
goes into how he schedules deep work how
he has different opinions on how to
schedule it and I learned a lot from
this book it's still one of my favorites
and I revisit it a lot of times and I
also want to say if you have any tips or
tricks for me or if you know an amazing
way to get to deep work I would love to
hear them so put them down in the
comments below and otherwise see you
next week bye